desde que los combates entraron en
erupción en jartum El Éxodo de aquellos
que huyen de la violencia en Sudán ha
sido interminable bajo el temor de
quedar atrapados en el fuego cruzado
estos civiles no solamente le están
dando la espalda a sus hogares sino a su
país algo que eleva los temores de una
potencial crisis de refugiados es algo a
lo que naciones vecinas como Etiopía
tendrían que hacer frente el país más
poblado del cuerno de África ya alberga
acerca de un millón de refugiados muchos
de los cuales son de Sudán una crisis
migratoria podría dar un vuelco a la
seguridad en la frágil región cinco de
los siete países con los que Sudán tiene
frontera ya viven conflictos armados
además de La amenaza de esa crisis de
refugiados a algunos también les
preocupa que los combates sirvan como un
instigador para otros ejércitos en la
región es un peligro que de acuerdo con
este experto ya las naciones de la
región están al tanto
algunos estados Árabes y extranjeros
pueden no importarles lo que ocurre en
Sudán pero la mayoría si no todos no
quieren que este conflicto continúe
porque es un contraste a lo que está
teniendo lugar en la región árabe Ley
Ley
en un intento porque la pasa regrese a
Sudán los presidentes de Sudán del sur
Kennedy guti dicen que quieren reunirse
con las fuerzas rivales temen que
mientras el conflicto se profundice haya
fuerzas extranjeras que quieran
intervenir tal y como es el caso de
Libia en donde varios actores en
regionales y globales compiten por la
influencia es un escenario que la unen
africana quiere evitar para Sudán